so what does this dead ugly succulent
and this stinky running shoe have to do
with getting more views and making money
on YouTube well the answer is actually
everything and we're gonna be talking
about that in this video in just a
second but I want to welcome you to the
think marketing QA show I am joined by
Melissa and Heather on the show today
how's it going guys going great I'm
excited to get into some questions I'm
excited to hear about that running shoe
and the plants yeah yeah yeah it's
something powerful and this is a Q&A
show so if you are here live then give
us your questions wherever you're
watching a couple question marks before
and after we're gonna start with YouTube
questions and sowed in and the think
team will be capturing those Melissa how
are you feeling I'm feeling pretty good
I'm actually more curious to hear about
the succulents that is very sad right
now
yes right I mean this thing is not
looking good and so we are gonna be
getting into all kinds of YouTube tips
as well as answering your questions but
to start it out what does this dying
succulent and running shoe have to do
with YouTube really everything because
here's what we need to know YouTube of
course is the second largest search
engine in the world and there's never
been a better time than right now to be
building your influence on YouTube now
of course we want to be empathetic that
we're living through some of the
craziest most turbulent times in the
world there's a lot of economics are
being displaced over 10 million
Americans have applied for unemployment
Japan is releasing trillion-dollar
stimulus plan so globally we're going
through so much but we really here at
think media and think marketing are here
to help you adapt and pivot to these
times and there's really never been a
better time to be creating content and
the reason why is because YouTube is not
only a search engine but recent stats
from Yahoo Finance showed us that
YouTube traffic overall is up 66% so
people are looking for problems to be
solved on YouTube the world has a lot of
problems right now
but you're an entrepreneur you're a
content creator it's your job to saw
and answer those problems what we'd like
to say is answer specific questions so
really what does this dead succulent
have to do with YouTube well everything
because every so often I love having
succulents here in my home office I put
them on my little window seal here to
kind of give me a vibe and you know try
to actually work from home tell me in
the comments if you've been working from
home and that's new for you and so I've
been always buying these but you can see
this thing is just getting wilty it's
dying because I don't know how to take
care of succulents in fact so much so
that I just rebuy them like every two
months from Trader Joe's for six bucks
because I'm so terrible at caring for
succulents well just a few days ago what
happened was I was like man I gotta fix
this pattern of toxic succulent murder
you know what I mean like I just there's
this guy this is wrong it doesn't feel
right and so what did I do I went to
youtube with a specific question you
need to be answering specific questions
on YouTube so what specific questions
can you be answering for your niche that
people are searching for especially
right now during this time so here's
what I did I went to YouTube and I'm
going to pull up my screen here for you
and I typed in like how to not kill
succulents or something think about that
was you want to think about what is it
that your audience is typing in what is
it that the person searching for your
video is typing in or I think I typed in
how to keep your succulents alive and
ultimately what it led me to was this
video right here and now I'm watching
this video from succulent Fame and I am
thinking okay I don't want to keep rebuy
in these succulents now let's look at
this video this video has 643 thousand
views with CPM which is how much YouTube
ads pay you this video in the last
couple years has probably generated
somewhere around 1000 to 2000 or 2500
dollars so think about the power of
making money on YouTube by just
answering a specific question but it
doesn't really stop
there because as we go through the video
some of the things that we teach here at
think marketing and think media is like
affiliate marketing and in this video
she talks about this succulent plant
food guess what you can buy that on
Amazon so if she actually doesn't have
affiliate links but she could say hey
look besides watering him in this
particular way you also want to get this
plant food you know you also might want
to pick up this little moisture meter to
determine if you
I learned the number one reason
succulents die is because of over
watering do you see how powerful this is
by just answering specific questions it
could lead to 643 thousand views of just
sharing your expertise and information
from what it is that you help people
with so remember on YouTube if you want
to build a channel right now you want to
build a side hustle right now you're
trying to make extra money you're trying
to figure out how to pivot in this
economy you got to be answering specific
questions now
if you've got a question about YouTube
specifically we're gonna start with
those on today's Q&A show I'm gonna tell
you about the running shoe in a second
but Heather Melissa what do you think
about the power of this and and how this
could be practical especially in these
times yeah well I know I'm doing the
exact same thing I am looking up the
stupidest things that feel really dumb
that I don't know but they're really
really incredibly specific questions
like how do I grow carrots from carrot
stumps in Las Vegas in this particular
kind of dirt in April
like that's how specific I'm asking
questions and the people that are being
the most specific in their YouTube
videos are the ones that I am clicking
on so it's really powerful for me as a
consumer yeah even for music consumer
our dishwasher it started to leak and I
was I mean I could call someone to go do
that but instead I went to youtube and I
typed in how to get your dishwasher to
stop the leaking when it's running I
type that whole thing into the YouTube
search bar and there were some great
videos that came up and here's the thing
there was about two to maybe two or
three videos that
had like kind of ugly thumbnails I
didn't click on them there was a lady
pointing at a dishwasher and I was like
I'm gonna click on that one because I
want to hear what she has to say and she
taught me how do you take my dishwasher
out how to check all the different
things she said these are maybe the
mistakes that could be happening what
tools I would need she walked me through
the whole thing
I have never fixed the dishwasher in my
life but because I typed in those
specific questions all of a sudden I am
Tim the tool man Taylor Sean I can fix a
dishwasher I thought I was pretty pumped
yeah that's amazing and so oh if you're
watching this video right now tell us
what is a specific question that your
audience target audience is asking that
you should maybe answer next tell us in
the comments and if you got value out of
this video so far hit the like button
but let's talk about the shoe and so
when we think about this there's so many
different niches right now that maybe
you could pivot into or that you are
already in and you could be making the
right video ideas for right now YouTube
traffic is up 66% more people have time
at home they're quarantined and so I
think about this I'm a hobbyist runner
and so I enjoy running as an
entrepreneur helps me clear my head and
sometimes though I just run out I kind
of get up I try to stretch out I go
running I get a little pain in my back
because I don't stretch out well well I
went to the Internet
the youtubes and I actually looked up
and I was like runner I first looked up
yoga for runners and I saw a couple of
different yoga workouts I saw like a
post workout I'm like well that's not
right
thirty minutes I was like forget that
that's gonna have 30 minutes that's like
I'm gonna be out of energy before I even
start running and so I eventually found
this seven-minute pre run and so I
watched this with yoga for Adriene
now again how do you make money on
YouTube this video came out in 2017 yet
I was watching it yesterday and it now
800,000 views from an adsense
perspective this video has probably
generated $1,500 2500 maybe even three
thousand dollars and so super powerful
but then I kept going and I looked for
more warm up so I looked for like a
runner warm up and remember YouTube is a
search engine so you want to be making
search based content and YouTube is an
accelerator that gives you an
opportunity to build know like entrust
with your target audience I found this
video this is Holly I feel like we're
best friends now because now I've done
this one a couple days in a row and she
has given me the seven-minute warm-up
and so that's why just a running shoe
just a hobby that I have I'm now talking
about her brand in front of you and this
runners experience channel because of
the difference I made in my life but
even more so this channel video has two
hundred and seventeen thousand views and
the run experience is just crushing it
with all types of different topics and
video ideas for yen people are trying to
run maybe they're still allowed to you
know stay social distance but go out 1.2
million views a month that could
probably equate to anywhere probably
around 2,500 to 5,000 dollars or more in
ad revenue but then of course they're
building their business with
subscription programs apps courses and
different aspects where they can
monetize in multiple ways so my friends
you need to be thinking about what is
the specific questions that are
search-based that you could be posting
on YouTube especially right now what are
the types of things that people are
searching and looking for and then how
can you connect those to monetization
and different ideas I want to remind you
if you've never seen our free
masterclass I think master class comm
you could get access to a 90 minute
training where we talk about how to come
up with those specific video ideas do
the tagging do the keyword research but
you need to asq answer specific
questions not just any question that you
want to add necessarily answer think
about these are real questions about
carrots about not killing your
succulents about warming up for running
and there's a million other topics that
people are interested in learning right
now and so you know before we get into
some of these questions
Heather Amell
some of the things that you have seen on
YouTube plus how think media has been
doing this yeah I think one of the
things that we really want to focus on
especially I think media is answering
creators questions and so we do things
like how to get a blurry background
that's a very very important thing if
you want to get a blurry background but
guys I'm not a tech guy a tech person
like Shaun and Omar and Nolan all the
creators on the think media team I'm
just an entrepreneur who knows how to
create ads and build funnels and knows
copywriting and all those things and so
I would search something saying how to
get a blurry background but even someone
like Shaun and O'Mara Nolan they
understand that that's actually depth of
field and so even when you're thinking
about specific questions and how you're
using that make sure you're actually
using your audience's words what are
they saying how are they saying it so
even I think media we do things like how
to make at the mill thumbnail with your
smartphone that is so specific it's not
just how to make a thumbnail it's how to
make a thumbnail with your smartphone
and a countless other examples but these
are my favorite types of videos to watch
because just like Sean said about the
girl that was teaching him running I
have so many people now on YouTube that
I specifically follow for specific
things and they are the people that I
know like and trust they're the people I
will buy from because I see them over
and over and over being the person who's
answering my questions what about you
male
[Music]
we iterate that point of just making
sure you're taking a step back and
thinking about where your audience is in
their journey and always trying to dumb
the question like done the question down
essentially like how can I make this as
basic as possible so one of the problems
that I always have is I'll tell Sean
sometimes like I don't even know how to
search for this like I don't know what
the proper term is to search for this so
I'm just putting like full sentences
into the YouTube search bar trying to
figure something out and so if you can
really put yourself in that position
just again reading what Heather is
saying but put yourself in that position
of somebody who doesn't know anything
about what you're going to teach them
and just answer those most basic
questions that's where you're gonna get
the most traffic and honestly like
you're gonna be the most help there
because somebody like me who knows
nothing about gardening and wants to
start getting into that needs those
really basic things first man those are
such good tips and if you're given value
hit the like button and we have some
great questions coming in right now
Peter says actually how do I use hash
tags on YouTube videos and we actually
have some we've done a lot of specific
you know testing with that and here's
kind of the conclusion that we've come
to at think media right now we're using
them mostly for branding when you use
them for like search based content it
doesn't necessarily work like hashtag
YouTube tips and even if it does
sometimes we found that it's hard to
quote unquote rank for those but even
the videos that do have like two views
or whatever so here's just kind of our
perspective I think sometimes yes maybe
go for trends sometimes yes maybe
there's a specific hashtag you actually
want to go after but on this recent
video that we did with Heather and I on
thick media we did hash tag think media
our brand we did hash tag Shawn Cannell
and actually we have think marketing on
here as well we will be doing hash tag
Heather Taurus at some time so when we
click think marketing look it organizes
our content and our brand because if
someone even accidentally clicks these
two you want to make sure that it kind
of links back to your stuff and so Nolan
moult on the think media team just put
a new iMovie editing video we recommend
if you have iMovie so it's think media
Sean kennel and Nolan mole and if you do
Nolan mole it'll actually organize not
only his think media tutorials but it
actually links to some of the stuff
that's on his channel as well and I saw
one of these somewhere that had maybe
it's the latest think marketing episode
but if you do hashtag Heather tourist
what's cool is again it could
potentially bring up not just her home
school channel and it kind of organizes
and brands all of her content together
but there you go it's also the latest
think marketing episodes so they're not
in my opinion very strong for growth
they're not really in my opinion very
strong for even getting discovered I
think there's some cases where that
could apply Peter but more than anything
I would think about what is kind of the
brand names your personal name your
business name your brand name that you
want to cluster your content together
and potentially buckets then that can
really help you there making dough show
says we own two pizzerias and we're
looking to figure out how we can add
more streams of income through YouTube
and beyond would greatly appreciate some
feedback and so I'm gonna kick it to
Heather and Mel here and we're gonna
bring up the making dough restaurant
show and so Heather Mel what do you
think about especially right now of
course restaurants are being shut down
and they're kind of on hold for a while
so what would what could we do here to
pivot and adapt with a YouTube channel
like this yeah I think well one I see
that you are teaching other business
owners how to be a business owner so
that's really great because you're
already starting to do that I'm seeing
here like restaurant marketing I would
also be thinking about how can you even
just pivot your own business so I know
you're doing pizzeria but like can you
teach people how to make pizza from home
what does that look like to be a
customer or consumer who's not able to
necessarily go to your restaurant but
I'm seeing here like making dough show
really looks like it's more geared
towards the business owner so I would be
thinking about things like what did you
do to get started what was your story
how did you how did
implement certain parts of growing your
business and while you're on hold right
now be thinking about what are skills
that you currently have that you could
be using in other ways and what do you
want to teach people right now that they
could be doing to grow their business so
I'm seeing here's some different just
looking at the channel overall I'm
seeing different styles of thumbnails
and look at the growth I mean you got
3800 views in the last 30 days that's
growth i Sean said it yesterday I love
that it looks like a heartbeat you're
growing it's alive and you're growing so
I would one I would start reaching out
to your audience I think a lot of times
we like to create content and isolation
we're not actually asking the people who
are the ones that are consuming it so
have you created a Facebook group for
other people who would like me business
owners like you are you a part of
different networking opportunities and
how are you reaching those customers
saying what value can I add to you you
know here at think media we almost I
would say weekly if not more times more
times than not we are asking people I'm
sorry my dog and my kids this is life
guys hello we are here in real life in
real form Cyrus can you please put him
in there so what I would say is are you
in these groups asking people here at
think media what we do consistently is
ask people how can we help you where are
you getting stuck what questions you
have we are doing it right now we're on
a live saying what YouTube questions do
you have we want to help and so I think
when you come out as the authority and
the person who wants to be the person
helping others that's when you'll start
to see the growth that's when you'll
start to see the change and you'll start
to figure out Wow a lot of people are
asking me about this I didn't even know
that that's something they wanted to
know and you might find that that's the
next business opportunity for you to
start teaching in yeah and I wonder too
I'm not sure if you're keeping it open
because you could still do delivery and
you could still let people pick up
depending on where you're located
you know delivery apps are through the
roof and I think that if you since
you're already kind of in educating
other business owners I think that'd be
interesting to look into
new videos educating other business
owners how to get on different delivery
apps tips and biggest mistakes from food
delivery apps how to avoid the most
common mistakes like food not not
showing up or how to make how to
reconcile the fees or ways to be
creative and at times you could get
affiliate Commission's for getting
people to sign up for like I know if you
get uber drivers to sign up and you
recommend someone to be an uber driver
uber eats you know whatever you get an
affiliate Commission and there's blogs
like the rideshare guy so if if you
adapt your business to keep the food
going even though maybe people can't
come in ultimately like eat in the
pizzeria then how are you doing that and
how are you helping these other business
owners go on digital keep their sales
going which then pivots into why they
need to master social media because they
might not just be on those apps there's
major competition there so then what are
people doing maybe locally there's a
million things then like following
hashtags like loke locations on
Instagram whatever so that they can have
awareness so that people want to go to
the app to deliver the food connecting
affiliate income streams around that I
think would be a really powerful
opportunity for you to consider
but as Mel gets the next question ready
for us hit like if you're getting value
and if you're new here this is what
what's called Vegas influencers a local
meetup we do in Las Vegas we all live in
Las Vegas right here at different places
we're coming to you from our home
offices where the think media team and
our passion is helping you with the best
tips and tools for building your
influence with online video and we're on
a mission to help 10,000 people create a
full-time living doing what they love
with online video and social media and
so this is now a Q&A show that instead
of just doing it here local in Vegas
it's online so we thought we'd open it
up to you in the community worldwide so
tell us where you're watching from
whether you happen to be checking this
out anywhere online tell us in the
comments where you watching from smash
like if you're fired up and grateful and
choosing to be positive in the midst of
a pretty crazy world we're living in
today and now what's the next question
our next question is from AC designs
I think this is a really powerful
question because it really touches on
the importance of your YouTube title the
importance of an eye-catching headline
that will address people's needs and so
AC Designs asks I'm a DIY Channel
should I always start my titles with
how-to awesome awesome so you know first
of all I don't speak Spanish but I
definitely understand that it's a major
niche a major group of people looking
for content it's awesome to see 24
uploads you know a month two hundred new
subscribers growing in 51,000 views so
things are definitely going well here
for you and you course want to double
down I don't think you only need to
start with how-to but I can kick you a
few of the most powerful titles that I
think about and that is this you know
how to you know use Photoshop is
definitely a good one but you also might
say Photoshop versus so write down the
vs. title like there's a real there's a
lot of opportunity where people are
looking for versus everything like
friends this is a YouTube tip that will
a smart YouTube idea as the title of
this video that can really help you what
can you do versus of like this first
that like Photoshop verse canva like
this company verse that company or this
product first that product you know we
do Canon m50 vs. Canon m6 on and so
definitely sort of the vs. and then
there's also like other structures in
terms of titles so I encourage you if
you ever you know we studied this at a
deep level feel free to of course always
look at our channel and look at what you
can learn so even though this iMovie
video is that we just put out is a
how-to video technically it actually is
titled iMovie editing tricks 10 easy
tips for beginners to your point how to
make a YouTube thumbnail with your phone
the best all-around that's another title
that you could grab the best like what
is the best free software for doing DIY
design if that kind of looks like what
your channel is and so you definitely
see we have the how Tube
also we have ones that kind of break the
pattern and what we've been teaching a
lot of in YouTube hyper-growth blueprint
and our VRA training programs is
actually a new school kind of structure
of titles that you want to have kind of
a mix of both
so why you need the $69 lens is less
kind of search based but nevertheless it
actually is still ranking in search
that's a whole topic for like another
time but those are just a few title
ideas that I think can help you when it
comes to you don't absolutely need to
only do how-to there's a lot of options
and opportunities for you great so our
next question is from dr. I house he
asks how often would you recommend
making YouTube community posts and
YouTube stories man Mel and Heather are
huge on this and so I'm actually gonna
kick it to Mel first who does a lot of
the community posting on our channel so
Mel what are your thoughts yeah I think
something that we've definitely instated
in the last you know later half of the
year is that we want to be posting far
more regularly on YouTube community
because that is where we have such a
huge community on YouTube in general and
so why not utilize that tab I don't know
about you but I've been using YouTube on
my phone a lot more as I'm just lounging
around the house every once in a while
and just have my phone and that's where
I see YouTube community posts so much
more frequently because the YouTube app
on the phone promotes it a lot and so I
am seeing YouTube community posts all
the time and I won't get tired of it so
if you know if I'm seeing somebody
posting three times a day it honestly
wouldn't even occur to me I wouldn't be
like they already posted today I would
just be like oh cool another post for my
favorite creator and so my general
answer is that I don't think you're
probably on the verge of posting too
much on YouTube community I think you're
probably not hosting enough and so we're
just aiming right now for four times a
day three or four times a day and we try
to do different kinds of content
I think that's important not just
constantly posting your own video but
maybe giving some kind of encouragement
engaging with your community can you ask
them questions maybe can you shout out
related content somebody else that's
doing really great things in your in
your niche those kinds of things that
are truly community building and get a
little bit more content like that on a
regular basis yeah I think it's the
other kind of thing we've learned that's
pretty powerful is they make it easy for
you to just share a video because what
you can ultimately do is you could
either do a video or you could do a poll
or an image or just text only and we've
learned that when you actually do an
image with a youtube link it radically
outperforms actually just linking the
video so you can see here by the way
community tabs also it wants it to be
square so we've you you want to either
you can just let the image be cropped or
you could just kind of throw up a
different version of your thumbnail and
there's a little bit of text we point to
the the youtube link being out and and
you know of course according to the size
of our channel but you know 253 likes
and 6 comments on this and a lot of
engagement with the views that we'll get
there if we just do the native YouTube
posting with the youtube link it doesn't
get as much real estate it seems to not
even get as much reach and therefore
that's something to experiment with but
we definitely say lean in on those
images and then this is kind of a bonus
tip for the community that came up
recently at another time and that is
Heather just mentioned it leaning on
audience feedback more like what can you
do if you want some smart YouTube ideas
right now by the way you need a thousand
subscribers to use your community tab
but you could do a Twitter poll you
could do Facebook polls and groups
you also can just log about a question
it doesn't have to be a poll and so one
of the best things you could do during
this time is think about how can you
maybe do a poll on Twitter on your
community tab to get video ideas of what
you should do next or what people are
feeling or feedback people love taking
polls I know I do same thing on
Instagram stories because it's so easy I
I feel like my finger magnetically
having to answer because I'm like I'm
given two options three options I have
to answer this get feedback from your
community right now and your next best
video idea that could blow up very well
could come from asking and connecting
with even if you're followed by ten
people serve the two that respond and
make the content they're looking for
when you do for one which you hope to
someday do for a million that's really
how you build a powerful brand over time
yeah and can you pull that back up we
had a question about where is the
community tab so the community tab is
located on your home screen
you've got home videos playlists and
then when you get to that amount of
subscribers but is it a thousand Shawn a
thousand subscribers yeah then you'll
have the ability to do a community tab
and here's what I would say you want to
double down on wherever your influence
is the most and so for us YouTube is
where our influence is the most and so
we want to be we want to be in people's
feeds and because we have so many videos
just like I know you do doctor eye
health you can be promoting older videos
to start to re-engage people in those
videos so what we will do is we will
cycle through our top ten videos lean in
did you hear that have you promoted your
top ten videos recently bet you have it
go back and reap remote those again
because if that's where the views are
coming from go back through and reap
remote those to your audience because
you're gaining subscribers if you're
growing on YouTube you're gaining
subscribers which means people don't
know that you have a video about X Y & Z
so reshare it to them and that's gonna
help reengage that video and you
wouldn't you then will have given them
another piece of your content to watch I
can align the think water branding mark
with my think on my hat if I do it right
how cool is this Pat that that's
actually one of the best tips to is
memes gifts they could really get
attention
yeah gifts count as images so you can't
put a video up there but you can create
a gif gif gift is a gift guys what it
what do you think tell us in the
comments is it ji FF jiff or is it gift
just in your pronunciation phonetics of
it what a debate what a worldwide global
controversy well what do you say it is
gif gif Shawn what do you vote gif okay
we're all in the same boat and that gets
attention thinking about motion that's
you know that's a power of video in
general like video on Facebook video in
youtube or gifts in that case that's
actually why when you hover over YouTube
videos it plays you a preview because
motion catches the human eye and so I
yeah we see pretty much a unanimous Doug
though says jiff but
good guff guff is a gif jiff Wow Oh Doug
said no he's backpedaling so I love it
man but yeah so community tab definitely
promoting your last past 10 and one just
quick think if you're like wait a minute
I hit a thousand subscribers I don't
have it when we started think marketing
which is a relatively new you know
project for us just this year even once
we hit a thousand it took like a week it
takes like a while to show up so as soon
as you had a thousand and it's like not
that day give it some time but then
eventually your communities have can
grow and by the way as we is we get
ready for the next question definitely
make sure you're subscribed here on
youtube if you're watching this
somewhere else
get over to YouTube on think marketing
channel hit subscribe or whatever your
favorite platform is because every week
Heather is the host of the think
marketing podcast and we just had Pat
Flynn on we've had some great past
episodes that you'll love Spotify Google
Apple podcast Android we're everywhere
wherever you want to listen or watch the
video podcast so definitely check that
out hit like if you've been getting
value in this video what's the next
question down low street scene ask
I've started my channel for my brand
it's still new how do I grow and make
interesting content for my viewers
without asking them directly what they
want really really good I would just
quickly call you back to what we started
with and that is that you want to answer
specific questions the cool thing about
the internet right now is that it
actually there's keyword research tools
that will will tell us exactly what
people are looking for so maybe this
seems to me that it's maybe a car
detailing type of channel and so let's
check out Ober suggests this is a
keyword research tool there's a free
version there's all you can also do a
paid version and so let's see like
fabric cleaner is what I'm gonna look it
up and maybe I'm gonna go fabric car
cleaner cuz that seems like that might
be your niche I'm gonna sign in here
just cuz I'll get a little bit of better
data on ubersuggest and again you could
use just the free version and you could
get a lot of cool feedback from the
interest and video ideas that you should
be making and whether or not they're
good video ideas to make so you know
when I type in fabric car clean or 880
people are searching that a month on
Google and we share a lot of other
keyword research tools unlike our free
master class I think master class but if
we go to keyword ideas here
there's a couple different we rotate
through tools to get insight about what
is the best video idea we should make
now on a practical level answer specific
questions fabric cleaner for car seats
I throw best in front of that what's the
best fabric cleaner for car seats based
on my thought that this is what your
channel is about
I would then assume that there's
probably a hundred other things you
could think about you know how to get
out coffee how to get out gum but then
if it's other aspects of cars a million
things you know I'm actually right now
because I have not been able to clean
our garage and move things around or
whatever we have our
cars parked in our driveway that is fine
except for in summer it's about to be a
hundred degrees and the Sun is out
constantly in Vegas and I don't want to
ruin our paint jobs so in hopes of that
I've been thinking okay do I wax it do I
clear coat next level and then I heard
there's like that crazy level and I saw
I've been trying to get information I'm
confused I need some help I need you to
make some videos there's so many
specific things but you want to be
answering specific questions and doing
your research research before you press
record and again if you haven't checked
out our full class on that we go a
little bit deeper and that's a big topic
we talk about a lot here at think
marketing okay so Glen is a student of
video ranking Academy and wants to know
they're about to launch in two weeks and
they want to know how can they get off
on the best foot Heather what are your
thoughts yeah I would say first you um
so you're about to get started
you need to get started that's number
one so you need to get started and
here's what we do as creators we will
find all the excuses to not press record
so I want you to definitely get started
you are a member of video ranking
Academy which means that you understand
our seven step framework for how to
actually do your YouTube videos how to
get them ranked how to get the right
videos out so that you can create
revenue in your business so here's what
I would say number one you need to just
get started because your first videos
are still gonna be your worst videos -
you should answer specific questions
we're hitting this one hard tonight
because it's so important that we're not
just lobbing out content but they were
being intentional about being the person
on the other side of people's questions
so number one get yourself started
number two answer specific questions and
number three do not pay attention to
your analytics at first I know it sounds
weird but here's what I want you to do I
want you to have the head knowledge to
know what you should be looking for but
I really want you to be working on being
consistent where creators start to go
wrong is they'll pump out a lot of
content and
they'll stop and then they'll wonder why
their YouTube channels not growing and
we'll look at their channel and we'll
say you're not being consistent so what
you need to work on first is getting
started answering specific questions and
staying consistent with creating content
then once you have those first couple
videos up you're starting to see some
traction once you get about ten videos
in then you can go in and you can look
and say how many people are watching
what's my click-through wait when our
people are dropping off on the videos
when you start getting enough answers
through the analytics you can start then
making strategic decisions on how to
pivot your content I think it's really
really important as creators that we put
the blinders on at first because what we
really need to work on first is
ourselves I know it sounds crazy but
you're making content for other people
but the first thing you're working on is
getting all the camera gear set up
batching your first set of videos
understanding how to edit titling them
caught doing the description getting
your thumbnails done that's a lot of new
learning that you're going through and
so at first it's not actually about the
other people viewing the videos it's
about you being able to create this new
skill this new routine in your business
so that you can see it get off to a
great start
Mel anything to add to that I think that
was perfectly said the biggest thing is
just to get started I know you want to
launch with everything all pretty
packaged and ready to go and feel like I
am ready to do this but the fact is is
that you you're probably not going to
have that complete common peace and
organization that we all crave trust me
Heather and I very organized people we
understand the feeling so you just have
to do it you just have to do it and you
have to keep doing it no matter what
happens that's the other biggest key you
might get zero views on your first video
keep going so good Mel what's the next
question so our next question is from
Cole and they're wondering about batch
producing which I know is a big passion
subject for you Shawn something you you
and Heather are well experienced with so
they're wondering how they can batch
produce content for YouTube and social
media they just want to be more
consistent with their posting yeah I
love it I'm going to kick it to Heather
and I'm going to pull a video and put
that in
the Comets so you guys could see some
deeper training that we have on that
yeah I was gonna say we we have a video
over on Shawn's other channel video
influencers where we walk through we did
a behind-the-scenes of a batch day of
them of Sean and and Benji shooting I
think it was eight videos maybe it was
like eight or nine videos and that's a
lot of videos I do not expect your batch
days to be eight or nine videos that's
after years of practicing how to do this
but here are some key things to remember
when you're doing your batch day one you
want to actually plan your videos not on
the day that you're shooting your videos
that's tip number one you should have a
separate day or you're planning out your
scripting out your bulleting you're
getting those ideas fleshed out before
you even get to the batch shoot day the
second thing you want to do is make sure
you have all of your camera equipment
ready to go if there's one thing we've
learned from doing hundreds of that
shooting is is that if your gears not
ready you're not ready so make sure that
your gear is ready to go meaning your
batteries are charged your stuffs in its
place it's ready it's set up for you to
just come sit down and record those
videos and then third here's a tip that
I did not do when we did our first batch
shoe of the think marketing podcast I
forgot to bring extra shirts I know it's
crazy so if you look at our first I
think it's six episodes of the think
marketing show I'm wearing the same
grade ten episodes 10 episode y'all 10
episodes Heather's wearing the same gray
sweater and someone made a comment to
about that they were like Heather must
really like that sweater here's the tip
when you're doing a batch shoot day
bring more than one outfit change your
hair change your earrings put the hat on
change the jacket our trick if you
notice I think media you'll start to
notice this now when you watch our
content is that we usually wear multiple
layers so right now Sean's got a show
show yourself Sean I need to show this
model Sean right now Sean modeling he's
got them on and off
he's got the jacket I can just throw it
it's throw four different things on so I
don't actually have to yea just boom
boom boom and it's like there's four
weeks there's four weeks of content so
those are my three biggest tips for a
bad shoot days and then my third bonus
tip it's probably
not gonna go the way you want it to go
our eyes are bigger than our stomachs
every single time we see town for a bat
shoot day so do not get discouraged just
schedule your next next batch shoot day
but those would be my biggest tips from
doing this and from learning through a
lot of our mistakes yeah and I'd finally
say as we get ready for the next
question
you know I saw Williams say 10 episodes
the same day that is not what you would
want to do first you know I think about
when you're you know just kind of
getting started I again I'm a hobbyist
runner early on and definitely check the
replay if you're just joining about the
power of the shoe because I love to run
I'm a hobbyist runner I've ran two half
marathons and every time when I'm
getting ready to run a half marathon I'm
like dude I'm gonna kill her you know
I'm gonna do a full I think we do a full
next time and whenever I finish a half
I'm like I am never doing and of course
I could work up to it but you have to
work up to you have to train up to it
and even I never thought I could run a
half marathon like 13.1 miles that's
crazy
it's kind of the same thing with content
creation so I think you know the tip
would be get your first video done like
if you haven't done one video yet like
post your first video and then get it
out on YouTube and then do your second
video but then eventually batch two
videos I'd be like oh cool did two in
one setting I'm compressing time now I
can do three or four when we did ten
it's kind of the equivalent of like
running a marathon and content we've
been doing this for a little while
like years now over a decade and so it's
definitely something to work up on work
up to but it's a key skill to learn
because y'all are busy you business
owners you're busy and it's not like
content creation is the only thing you
got to do you got to do QuickBooks and
you got to balance your finances and you
need to fill out documents and you need
to do emails and you know I have to
contact people and you got to do your
taxes come on you know what I mean like
there's all kinds of other aspects of
business and even you got to reach out
to brands and network with other people
and so we need to have smart systems
right in our businesses to get a lot
more done in less time and so check out
some of those resources that were
sharing with you we posted those in the
comments and I'm fired up I'm having fun
guys how what
sipping on you guys have any beverages
with you I've got this health aid
kombucha pomegranate right now I love
this this comment from William he said I
want to be you when I get older yeah
William it's taken years to get to the
level to be able to do ten episodes in
one time but like Shaun said it's the
systems that really matter and that we
just keep doing those systems and that
free video that we just shared that
should breaks on our entire system for
you so you can duplicate that what you
got Mel what are you sipping on though
wouldn't you sipping on Mel got the
classic water yeah water yeah Heather
and I are the mason jar fat people are
sometimes say oh the Mason family no but
like I have we yeah sipping our water
hey let us know Brandon still sipping on
coffee we are hanging out earlier on
coffee with Cannell tell us what you're
drinking in the comments below what's
your favorite beverage and what beverage
on Batsuit days is a coffee day for us
for sure and these days we've been
shooting at Omar's house who's like in a
coffee affection Otto like one of those
guys who like the altitude of where the
beans were grown like this the
temperature of the soil and the moisture
of the soil like soil temperature
altitude region fair trade he's doing
poor overs he's doing it he's doing
arrow presses I mean is my favorite
place to go like I just I just literally
am glad Omar's on the team for his
coffee contribution because that's how
we get through batch shoot days but the
next question is all right we've got
Jonathan asking about an old channel he
has from 20 2009 with 30 subs and wants
to know he wants to start getting back
into posting regularly once a no should
he post on that old channel or should he
just start a brand new one
does the YouTube algorithm care so
typically you probably could start
building on that channel Jonathan but
the only reason you'd really want to is
if you're going to this might not even
matter cuz you don't have that much
momentum with just the 30 subs but you
don't want to start trying to pivot a
channel and take it in a different
direction so a lot of people ask us hey
you know I was doing kind of this like
sewing channel
I abandoned it and now I'm thinking
about starting a new channel but it's
gonna be kind of all about how to grow
your business and like social media tips
we're like okay that's way different
than sewing and that will confuse the
YouTube algorithm I do think there's
some value to if you're just gonna
restart that you should in fact we had a
question in our community recently that
was like they were a Cooking Channel
they took some time off and they were
still gonna be a Cooking Channel and
they had a little bit of momentum and so
I think that's what it is Jonathan I
also wouldn't hesitate to start a new
channel at all I mean 30 subscribers
there isn't you know if you already have
some videos posted it does kind of give
you a head start there is an aspect of
YouTube that does like the age of a
channel but only if it's the same niche
that you're gonna be posting in great so
I think this next question might be
coming from a place of being a little
tired a lot because Alima is saying that
they're posting five videos a week right
now and can eventually they go down to
fewer videos a week Heather yeah take
this one yes I mean yes you can we we
really really um we really preach
quality over quantity and the only
reason you should be increasing your
quantity is if your quality can stay at
the same standard and five videos a week
I mean that is a lot of content I would
say can you do less videos better that
would serve your audience better we I
think media here now are a team of
creators and we are pumping out that
much content so to be thinking about one
person handling all that content I
understand there's daily vlogging I
understand that there's simpler content
that people can do but I would say could
you then be using that time wisely and
other ways to be growing your business
remember
YouTube is a platform where you can be
growing your business and so if you
could do less videos better and use that
time then to network on Instagram to be
commenting back to people to be
analyzing your analytics to see what is
working could you then be able to post
more videos when you have a team built
around you to help you do that
at that same quality I think that's when
you start to increase but really be
thinking can I do less videos better a
really good tip and that's what we'd
recommend for you in this community come
on right now if you haven't started
creating content now's the time
creators create content conceptions up
you've got time on your hands and more
people are consuming content YouTube
consumptions up 66% Nielsen reported
that content conception over the across
the board is up sixty percent and people
have problems we always got problems
right you're like yeah my wife's got
problems like you know you're like my
sister she's got a lot of problems but
like like people have problems any on a
serious note you know right now more
than ever before there's new problems
there's new challenges people need to
reinvent themselves they need to pivot
they are looking for things that they
can do from home they're trying to
figure out what to do with their kids
how to keep their marriage together how
to make masks how to do all kinds of
things as well as how to things we help
you with you know how to pivot make
money online do side hustles the point
is you gotta raise your voice right now
you gotta be creating content and what
we recommend is at least one video a
week because Heather said there's other
stuff to do there's other stuff to learn
there's other stuff to study yeah you
got to sharpen your skills yeah you
gotta you want to build your network
yeah you want to be learning and thanks
for being on a stream like this we truly
appreciate you being here whether you're
here live or on the replay we're
grateful for you and so there's a lot of
different things to do but keep that
pillar of at least one upload a week
going because that is really
foundational to breaking through
creators create content if you're a
Content reader or an entrepreneur that
knows you got to be in this content game
you got to be creating content right now
agreed 100% I am watching a lot of
YouTube so I know that is a reliable
statistic we have a question from
another video ranking Academy student
they're asking when VRA
point o is coming out and how different
it is from VRA 2.0
awesome question yes so video ranking
Academy is our signature YouTube
training course and it's a four year old
program but it's a program that we keep
updated with all the new changes with
YouTube and so now of course there's a
whole new YouTube studio there's all new
data that YouTube's giving us plus we
have friends like at vid IQ that did IQs
the software that's installed on a lot
of different computers
the data is anonymized so your data is
safe but they're able to get a lot of
insight about trends what's working what
keywords are happening they're always
evolving their tools so I think media
we're like scientists of YouTube that
are constantly thinking about what how
do you get an edge what are the newest
changes we're uploading so many
different videos across multiple
different YouTube channels we're always
experimenting so the new video ranking
Academy is the the new update is gonna
be progressive actually it's kind of
like Final Fantasy 7 remake they're not
they're putting it into like three or
four different games not just one so the
big first major chunk at the time of
recording this video is coming up next
week and it's gonna be we're doing a
live recording with the students where
you could be there live and it's gonna
all go in the members area and how
different is it foundationally it's
built off the same principles but it is
it's it's so it's essentially like the
same foundation 10x steroids like a lot
of steroids like an unhealthy guy is
still ripped he can you can't see his
neck anymore amount of steroids into new
strategies new workbook new downloads
and a lot of new tools that are gonna
really help you get an edge on YouTube
right now we've been especially in the
last eight months super deep in just
obsession with what is working on
YouTube right now which we always are
but like more so late lately and last
year
I invested tens of thousands of dollars
in my education to always you know not
only do I get to speak at events and
travel that includes you know traveling
going to different masterminds going to
different events learning and studying
the best practice
and that's what we're obsessed with and
then deliver that to you so be pumped go
into your private Facebook group Tania
and check your email because details is
rolling out when we're releasing it
you're absolutely gonna love it and we
can't wait to share with you save you a
question from peculiar pine tree which I
really appreciate the name it definitely
piqued my interest
asks question on spring off of a viral
video I had a video go semi viral around
100k views 100k views and I'm struggling
to bring the viewership to my other
videos that's a great question um you
know I think that when you have a viral
video it's a great opportunity for you
to Double Down you know and always
double down on what's working it looks
like a DIY custom gaming mouse a pad for
a $0 popped off went viral um we can see
here these are the tags that it's
ranking for so good job with keyword
research and different things and so I
think that what you want to do is is and
maybe you've already done this but the
initial next step whether a
quote-unquote viral or not for anybody
watching whatever topic that blows up on
your channel even if it's just a little
bit if like it's double triple 4x which
the views you normally get what's part
to think about part two like what is the
follow up to it what is part two to it
and then secondly though I wouldn't
worry about it too much it's actually
kind of the dirty secret about a viral
video and that is that it really won't
necessarily change your life it could
get a big big boost
it could get big awareness I remember
when think media had a random video I
don't think we go viral got 2.6 million
views and it was a boost in subscribers
it was a boost of momentum so yes it's
the kind of thing that will get your
channel to snowball a little bit but
here's the mindset I want you to have
it's always back to the grind in the
sense of it's coming back to the
foundation of consistency and uploading
one video a week I have a feeling at
least right and as like a baseline I
have a feeling that you might have seen
a little bit of a boost
and so as we're here coaching you know
this concerns me and you know and all
coaching I love you but I've seen zero
uploads so one of the best ways to
respond to a viral video is to keep
posting new videos post a part two but
you always got to come back to the
foundation of uploading consistent
content and you know the last uploads
where it looks like now seven months ago
and so there's no way to really maintain
growth without consistently following up
I hope you if you've got monetization on
that video you're probably still
experiencing some YouTube ads you know
and trickle in from the revenue there
but absolutely and maybe what you
experienced experience was I see even
months ago you're like shoot I got a
hundred thousand and then I kind of went
down to my newer videos not having that
many views and maybe it led to some
discouragement I don't blame you because
you're like oh this is this the new
normal a hundred thousand views and then
you're like oh actually the new normal
is going kind of back to just the
hardwork brick by brick by brick I'll
summarize by saying that it's really
YouTube as a commitment to both and in
our video raking Academy community we
talked about the baseball analogy and
what that is is when you are creating
YouTube videos you just want to keep
getting up to the plate keep swinging at
the pitches and going at it with all
your might doing your best and know that
even the best craters still strike out
you know they go for it they go for it
they strike out you're like shoot I made
a video it didn't do that good that our
goal in YouTube is to at least just get
on base what does that mean
that just means that even if it was an
ugly bunt you know like just we bunted
it like barely goes sprint to base get
on base and then people are like boohoo
that was so ugly that was terrible but
she like at least I'm on base man I
don't know it's a cheap bunt whatever
like even and that's just like a it's
not glamorous it's not a hundred
thousand views it's just the views
you're it's 200 views it's four hundred
views it's 855 use awesome then what
happens is though you keep getting up to
base every week you keep showing up keep
pressing record keep punching fear in
the face then you get up you you just
have that connection
Oh boom and it's either a home run or
maybe the bases are loaded and it's a
Grand Slam and that's where the quote
unquote viral which especially like so
many of our students and people in our
community have experienced that but it's
only really works when they're doing
both they every once in a while get
these videos that pop off and pop off
but then they're also just doing the
base hits and the combination of those
two things is this compound effect of
like just putting runs on the board runs
on the board and constant wins and so
stay committed to the process and I want
to encourage you most of all to get back
into the game and and keep posting again
because that's absolutely the best way
to follow up a viral video kind of like
the one you had a quick question which
software are you using get that question
a lot
so this software right here man is
software that we love
it's called stream yard and we actually
have an affiliate link with ten bucks
off we don't have an affiliation with
them it's not a sponsored video or
anything but we've been falling in love
with this software Heather I want to
hear why you love this software so much
in particular though yeah for me this
software is user-friendly this is for
the tech non-techies that's who I am and
I love this software because right now
we're actually streaming live on YouTube
and live on Facebook so we're able to
expand our reach through using this I
love that the backend interface I'm
actually going to be doing some
step-by-step tutorials on how to use
this software here on think marketing so
make sure you're subscribed but I'm
going to be walking you through how
you're able to use this back-end
interface you know we've Sean uses other
we've used other things here at think
media like mimics and OBS which are
great programs but I'm not a tech person
I need this to be easy and fast I've got
three kids a dog I'm homeschooling I
need this to move fast and I need it to
be easy to do and this software has
allowed us to reach so many people I
love that we've got this little branding
right here oh wow that's hard let's try
okay yep it's right above my head you
can brand it you can do different back
screens you can see that we're able to
just switch around you can see Sean
Melissa my
self were able to share our screen you
can do this my friends right now I have
a webcam and a microphone and an
internet connection and we are now
streaming to you on YouTube and Facebook
so we'll share more about that you can't
get $10 off it is a paid program but I
highly recommend this for any business
owners who want to be reaching their
audience through live streaming I also
love Sean real quick you can create
YouTube videos this is what I'm gonna be
doing for my youtube channel I'm gonna
be conducting interviews and doing it
unlisted re editing it this is how I'm
able to stream with multiple people on
for the interviews that I'm doing so
it's really important to have a software
that is easy to use that it does not
take a lot of tech experience to get
going and that you're able to use in
multifaceted ways yeah I totally agree
and you know the other thing is actually
you can grab stream yard free but you
just won't have the cool branding and
you'll have their branding on it but
we'd recommend again to step in maybe so
you can have your branding and the other
cool thing is you also can very easily
maybe make a little bumper or make a
video you can then upload it and you can
play it again as you mall or your
multi-streaming and Heather will do some
trainings to show you how easy it is so
we'll drop links in the description or
in the comments so you can check this
out if you want to learn a little bit
more about it with that let me show you
one of the videos that we have uploaded
here it's actually about our event
called groweth IDEO live that's coming
up this September some people's
questions were you know hey was it still
happening and you know we're taking a
day by day but here's the cool thing
three-day event Las Vegas or it's gonna
be happening online and it's gonna be
world-class there's gonna be all the
speakers there's gonna be connections
and community no matter which way so
we're gonna of course keep you posted
but this kind of gives you an example of
what you could do with stream yard and
how you could just play a video right
inside of the software so here's just a
little quick teaser of growth video and
then we will be back for a few questions
65 percent of people use YouTube to help
them solve a problem but when I think
about this here's what question all of
us need to hand
what problem do you solve you got to
know that and when you know that people
are going to the internet they go to
Google they go to YouTube to help solve
a problem you need to be showing up with
those answers
[Music]
my goodness there you go and that was
really Nolan on our team added that
together but I just have it in the super
easy user interface over here and you
know if you want to learn more about
growth video just go to grow with video
live.com we're so excited for it and
this is one of those crazy years man
life's been so disrupted obviously we'll
never forget and we're making the best
of of really a tough situation but it's
never been a more important time than
now to grow with video they do master
video and to master live streaming and
to learn these skills and so super
excited about that if you begin value
out of this video hit the like button
and we're just gonna land the plane here
with a couple questions journey to
wellness is asking as somebody with a
lot of different interests but not a lot
of experience in each of those interests
would it make sense to start a channel
documenting the process of learning
something Heather yeah I'd say there's
definitely some value in that um I would
also just say you know what is the skill
you want to develop did you know there's
courses online for practically
everything so I would recommend if
you're saying you know I have a lot of
different varying things but not a no
experience in any one thing I would
figure out I would take some time to do
some self-reflection and say what do I
want to learn what do I want to be known
for where could I go to find this
information
and so documenting the process I think
definitely has value to it I know
there's other entrepreneurs who say
document over you know making sure
you're documenting the process I think
there's value but at the same time if
you've throughout this live stream and
you'll hear us over and over at think
media say you want to be showing up to
be answering specific questions so
here's how documenting looked like for
me and my home schooling niche I have a
channel all about home schooling and I
started it when I would when I was a
homeschool mom for only a year so the
content that I was bringing to it was
saying hey I've been where you are I
know what it feels like to go through
the decision to home-school so here's
what I've done here's what I've learned
here's what I'm doing but I did it in
the context of day in the life
I did in the context of private or
public school versus home school I did
it through the research that I was doing
oh man look at that Wow
you're welcome Internet you're welcome
worlds that's right
so I edited this also on iMovie I just
learned but I digress let me go back I
documented the process through creating
videos that were searchable so typical
home school day has 22,000 views on it
that is a search term home school versus
public school is a search term so while
I was documenting and while I was
digging in and learning what is the
skill I needed to learn I needed to
learn how to homeschool my kids that was
the skill I needed to learn how do I do
this with all with my kids and my job
and my life and my husband and ministry
and all the things so I started
documenting as I was doing it but I
became an expert because I was the
person answering the question no one
actually dubs you with permission to go
into a field just so you know on YouTube
on social media in the world right now
you can become an expert at anything we
have the god-given talents to learn we
can do this and so if you're saying I
want to be known for X Y or Z whatever
that is I want to be known as a leader
in my community I want to be known as a
mother who helps other mothers I want to
be known as an entrepreneur who helps
other entrepreneurs but I do that
through the contacts of answering
specific questions so yes you definitely
can but I would challenge every one line
to get your journal out and say what
skills do I need to learn in 2020 its
skill based it's all about what you know
how to do so what do you need to go
deeper on and I'll bet there's a course
I'll bet there's a coach I'll bet
there's a mentor out there that can help
you get to where you want to go very
awesome tips and we're gonna take one
more question in just a second thank you
so much for being here live you know and
if you're watching the replay we hope
that you you know got a lot of value out
of this and we are gonna be doing these
for the foreseeable future twice a month
we are kind of working it out hey we are
painting the plane just like you we are
pivoting our plan in real-time this is a
time in history where we just did a
video on this channel about creating a
strategic plan but there's only a
certain dimension where you can plan you
plan a little bit you get clear you
figure out what your shortest path to
income what's your smartest path to
income and then you got to take massive
action and be willing to continuously
pivot so even with this we did a monthly
in-person Meetup called Vegas
influencers and now we can't meet up in
person but it birthed a brand new show
where we get to hang out with you online
and so make sure that you're on the
email list the best way to do that right
now is to go to Vegas influencers comm
which is kind of updated to a new
whatever its worldwide influencers
essentially and that way you'll get
notifications exactly when we're going
live you know get on here as quick as
possible and we'll try to get to your
question and and then once a week I'm
doing coffee with channel and say
connected to the podcast and to our main
channel a lot of content to help you
right now survive thrive and really
figure out how to adapt and pivot with
social media live streaming in online
video in what's happening in the world
right now but mal let's hit another
question before we land the plane yeah
and I just want to let people know that
we are taking as many questions as we
can this is our last question but if you
still have questions left that you're
wanting answered there are a lot of
different places and Sean just mentioned
a few different places where he's going
live and answering questions on a
regular basis sean is really putting on
the extra energy and to just being live
everywhere he can so you can really be
there for the community right now but we
also have if you're in VRA or I see
poster question the Facebook group
there's a lot of valuable comments that
are going to come in from other members
of the community as well as from the
sinc team post questions on our social
media posts ask your questions on
community tab or constantly asking you
what questions do you have each of
community tab Instagram Facebook just be
engaged now is the best time to be
engaged in community online do not be
isolated get get online get into our
community get into the thinking
community ask your questions we are here
for you and the whole community is here
to support each other which I really
love so if you didn't get your question
answered today just make sure that
you're hitting us up on all these other
platforms also where Sean mentioned
before but here we go here's our last
question I started my youtube channel
years ago then I got discouraged and
stopped I want to start posting again
how do I do that
do I just start posting it again mm-hmm
yeah really a really great question and
this is I want you to know that this is
actually completely normal we see this
happened to so many creators and my
first answer is yes start posting again
don't take it as a loss take it as a
learning experience and just start
posting again when is the best time to
start making videos on YouTube today
that's the best time so I totally
understand what this feels like the
discouragement the feeling of maybe
failure the feeling of should I be doing
this here's the thing when you're
starting on YouTube when you're starting
anything new it really is about working
on yourself first before it's about the
gratification of getting the numbers
that are happening online remember this
is a marathon not a sprint
and so sometimes in a marathon you gotta
just you gotta just run a little slower
sometimes you got to stop for the water
break sometimes you got his tires chew
again like it's okay to be someone who
isn't just creating all the time let me
tell you friends I have a youtube
channel right now Sean can pull it up it
shows a big fat zero on the content
creation I'm feeling it I know there's a
community that needs me and I want to be
creating content and I went through all
the feelings of should I be doing this
is this even a project I should be
focusing on I I kind of feel like a
failure I kind of feel like I'm letting
people down is this direction I want to
go is this what I want to be known for
all the same questions that you're
thinking we're thinking too but I just
want to say this is the time to be
creating if you have light to put into
the world this is the time to be doing
it I know that this can be hard I know
that the world is changing I know that
it can feel like is this what I should
be doing but if you're on the stream
right now and you can hear my voice then
you already know you should be doing it
so we need to double down
I want you to commit to creating content
I want you to actually move your future
forward while you're in quarantine while
you've got nothing else happening I want
you to double down if you're inside a
video ranking academy double down if
you're inside of inner circle double
down if you need help we are here to
help you but this that is not the time
to sit back and watch watch just watch
the time but go by this is the time to
claim every minute for moving your
future forward who man Heather droppin
some fire I felt that one hey think
media think marketing community smashed
like if you got value out of this video
we had a question people said is it
Vegas influence or calm influencers with
an S so there's an S on there if you
want to get notified at the next time
we're doing this in about two weeks and
we're gonna do this twice a month for
the foreseeable future RSVP or get on
the email list we would get all the
dates we don't know when they are
they'll be different nights or times and
so that way you get a heads up and you
know we'll alternate time so you have a
chance to be a part of one of these live
streams get your question answered and
always definitely check back for the
replay because you can see how packed
with tips and value that these are maybe
share this with somebody else that needs
some encouragement as well as some
strategy right now and and then Vegas
influencers com of course check out
details in the description down below
Chris Erica appreciate you being here
and if you want to check out the latest
episode of the think marketing podcast
or subscribe to the show just click or
tap the screen right now you can also
check the podcasts on Spotify in Google
as well as Apple podcasts but definitely
click or tap the screen right now cuz
you're gonna love the think marketing
show and we will see you in the next
video
take care